Do you see any value in a daily shot with the ingredients of juice of what organic lemon?
One tablespoon, good olive oil. One teaspoon black seed oil. I don't see any problem with that.
The only caveat to that would be you're taking a tablespoon of olive oil.
If a person doesn't have a gallbladder, that could be an issue, but if they have a gallbladder,
that could help their gallbladder flush, so that could actually be helpful.
I don't see any problem with that at all, so there's no negatives to that.
Do I know of a good olive oil? Well, you can go back and forth on all sorts of different
philosophies of what good olive oil is and that's not good olive oil.
It's just really hard to kind of wade through that muck.
I would just try to buy an organic olive oil and it's always good to try to buy one that's from
a single source. If you look on the back and it says product of Italy, then you know it's coming
from Italy. If it says product of Italy, Spain, and Portugal, then it's a mixed olive oil that they
may be cutting it with cheaper versions, so you'll want it to be a single source olive oil.
I know there's some places in olive vineyards in California where you can buy olive oil
straight from them. It's coming from one vineyard and I think you can get that from places in
Italy too. That's what I would at least have been taught to look for. It makes sense to me.